are so obsessed with getting credit yeah
okay but because nobody using
credit because you fake up I
invented Casey Musgraves in this house
okay I'll give you that I discovered
Megan Maroney no you didn't anyone who
had Tick Tock like of course like a year
before her first song ever came out I
knew about Megan Maroney so don't even
try I came up with Magnum no I
knew you were gonna say that no you
didn't I came up no you didn't know I
came up with the name Magnolia you did I
remember where we were I remember where
we were so Megan moroney Casey Musgraves
and Magnolia I didn't invent but like I
was the OG in this house of Taylor Swift
oh yeah that's fair I thought you were
gonna say Luke Combs actually I'm gonna
get out